Hey Jocko, what can we do with
a coworker who isn't on board?
When someone brings up something to him,
he gets defensive and turns it
into being everyone else's problem.
[inaudible] this was a Twitter
question by the way. And uh,
and I answered it and I answered it
really simply, really straightforward.
Take ownership of the problem, solve it,
take ownership of the problem and fix it.
Right? Cause think about
what's happening here, right?
The what the person is saying
like, Oh this is me saying, oh,
echo won't take ownership of the problem.
And every time I tell him he does
something wrong, he just gets defensive.
So I mean obviously I'm not
communicating with you well enough.
If all I'm doing is blaming you and
you're getting defensive. And by the way,
if I'm the type of person that
takes ownership of things,
why am I blaming you in the first place?
I should be looking at myself.
And by the way, if Echo,
if you point your fingers at me
and you say, Hey, this is my fault,
you know what I'm saying? Yeah, I agree.
It is my fault and here's what
I'm going to do to fix it.
Now I'm not going to rub it in your
face. I'm not gonna. I'm not gonna do it.
So I prove a point.
That's not what I'm doing.
I'm actually doing it because I want to,
when I'm actually doing it because
I want to accomplish the mission.
That's why I'm going to fix the problem.
Hmm.
Now, if we have a weak member of the
team that doesn't take ownership,
then guess what?
It's my responsibility to take
ownership of the problem and fix it.
And eventually,
but the good thing about this is if you
make an excuse about something and I
fixed that excuse and then you make
an excuse about something else,
I fixed that one.
And then you make an excuse about
something else and I fixed that one.
Eventually.
There's no more excuses for you,
and now you're left with what you can
actually handle as echo with no more
excuses to make. And then either you're
capable of, you're not in. By the way,
guess what?
As the leader,
then it's becomes my job to
get rid of you if you can't,
if you cannot do the thing that I asked
you to do or that you're supposed to do
for the team.
So,
okay.
Yeah, because I mean
eventually if you, if,
if I keep stepping up and
taking things away from you,
there's not gonna be any more excuses
and you'll either end up with no
responsibility and therefore no
value and then you have no job.
That's the way it works.
Now, let me ask you this.
When is there a time that a subordinate
does something
and it's not the leaders fault?
So,
so think about this.
W W W and when something goes
wrong with a team member,
when is it not the leaders fault?
So if you've got a machine gunner and
the machine gunner shoots outside of his
field of fire, clearly he didn't
pay attention during the brief.
That's the problem.
If I have a machine gunner that engages
non-hostile targets is a machine gunner
his fault because he didn't do improper.
He,
he did improper positive identification
of his targets and engaged
a friendlies or or at least non hostels.
So that's the machine goes wrong or the
machine gunners at weapon goes down.
Yeah
because the machine gunner didn't click,
it's his fault cause he didn't clean his
weapon, maintain his weapon properly.
The machine gunners fault.
So all those things,
the machine gunner shoots out of his
field of fire and a machine gunner gauges,
non hostile targets and machine
gunners weapon goes down.
All those of the machine
gunners fault clearly.
Okay.
Or maybe not so clearly because here's
how I would look at those things.
Cause by the way,
when I point if you're my machine gun
and I put my finger at you and start
yelling at you and telling you
that you did something wrong,
obviously we know what happens.
You start making excuses and blaming
other people and and you don't accepting
responsibility cause you get defensive.
And that's what people do. So for me
in what a good leader
does is a good leader.
When the machine gunner shoots out of
his, fueled the fire, the leader says, Oh,
you know what? I didn't explain the
fields of fire clearly enough for you.
I'm sorry, I'll fix it. Machine
gunner engages on non hostile target.
Then the leader says,
Hey,
I should have given you better
training on target identification.
We will go back and fix that.
Or the machine gunners, a weapon goes
down. It means that I, as the leader,
you know what? I should've done
a better job inspecting weapons.
I should have explained how important
the maintenance was. That's my fault.
I won't let it happen again.
So even in these instances where it's
real easy to blame the, the individual,
all good leader instead of blaming the
individual will take ownership of the
problem. That's what you do.
And that's what's going on.
In this case, you got a coworker
that's not on board and,
and just gets defensive and turns it into
everyone else's problem. That's right.
Grab ownership of those problems.
And by the way, the subordinate,
that's not taking ownership.
That's your fault as a leader and the way
that you get someone to take ownership
isn't by saying, Hey, don't get defensive.
You need to take
ownership of this problem.
It's your problem that doesn't
make people take ownership.
Here's the tricky part.
Here's the black belt situation.
The black belt situation is if I want
you to take ownership instead of blaming
you, I'm going to take, I'm going
to take ownership of the problem.
I'm going to relieve you of that and now
you're going to go way out. No, no, no,
no. I should be able to fix that.
I'm sorry boss. I'm sorry Jocko.
I shouldn't have shot my, I shouldn't
have shot outside the field of fire.
I need to pay better attention during
the brief if I don't know what it was.
I'm going to ask questions next
time. Are you sure? Yes, I'm sure.
Please let me get it fixed.
And that is how you get
someone to take ownership.
You don't get people to take ownership
by them to take ownership of things.
And there's a little dichotomy here too,
because if it's a plan,
then the way I get you to take
ownership of it is by saying, hey, echo,
come up with a plan. Like we talked about
standard operating procedures earlier.
If I come up with the standard operating
procedures myself and then I forced
them on to you. You don't take ownership
of those. Yeah, those are mine.
So I have to give you ownership,
but when it's a negative,
it's when it's a positive thing, I give
it to you. When it's a negative thing,
I take it,
I take it positive thing.
Give it,
cause people want that positive thing.
Yeah. When it's a negative thing,
they don't want it. You take
it from them and by the way,
when it's a positive thing
and you give it to them,
guess what they want to do with it? They
want to share it. They want to do it.
Yeah. When it's a negative
thing and you forced on them,
they want to get rid of it.
So there you go.
I'm glad that this person's in the game
and now they know how to handle this
coworker and make it
into a good situation.